in another dramatic day in the french
presidential race the former prime
minister as you pay has ruled himself
out once and for all he says and
criticized his parties in battle
candidate frost off vimeo who's at
fighting allegations that he misused
public funds straight to our London
studio central London studio we can
speak to dr. Andrew Smith the historian
of modern France at the University
College London hello T thank you for
joining us on Sky News this afternoon so
why is it first of all straight off the
bat that French politicians seem to be
able to get away with murder compared to
british politician well i don't think
they can to be honest like this is a
moment we're actually seeing this very
much so and there's been a big push
people expecting more from there from
the political leaders on sunday
obviously we saw a huge rally take place
in comparative standards and in support
of funeral this was his last gasp rally
that you my heir ran yesterday at the
same time there was also an
anti-corruption rally which ran just
across town and i think more and more
what we're seeing is a push against
corruption push against that sort of
nepotism people are attacking for you
for really at worst embezzlement and at
best a type of unsavory nepotism which
is really a ruling faith in politics so
i don't think there's any great shift
between what politicians can and can't
get away with i think this is really
just a case of chickens coming home to
roost okay so let me put it another way
then what what sort of impact will
what's happening at the moment have on
the other politicians within the race
yeah absolutely well you've already
mentioned allows you bare hand because
the reason we're talking about you
appear really is because feelings and
such a sticky wicket at the moment he
has had a lot of resignations around him
his team of standing down around amin
lost his campaign manager he's just
appointed a new one and but he's also
losing support party grandees who are
moving around him as well and really
there's a lot of pressure on for you
understand zone because that leaves the
huge gap he's standing for the less i
could leak and the French equivalent of
the Conservative Party and really
without feel it leaves a huge gap so the
question is who's going to take to yours
place if he stands down or if he
continues to run what does that do to
the race obviously the other two
candidates to
front-running candidates are macro and
the pen really this offers a lot of
possibilities for both and fiona has a
very conservative base older bourgeois
Catholic support base and actually they
have a natural home if something happens
to fianc candidacy with mocking the pen
and you have much more centrist interest
for Sam Blake emmanuel macron he's a bit
of luck in a political nowhere man but
he's also garnering a lot of support for
that people describe them as a sort of
almost new labour type figure for the
French either like right nor left but
somewhere in between business-friendly
not quite socialist but offering
something a little bit more liberal
perhaps that we might see when we're
looking at the polls poll schmelz you
know we've seen what happened with
directly we've also seen what happened
with President Trump but it is
suggesting that it is macarons rather
than the pens to lose where are you on
this yeah definitely is macross surging
in the polls and fiona is tanking at the
moment feels actually doing so badly at
the moment that even among the a not
very fancy term Socialist Party
candidate is starting to look like he
might push for equivalents and there was
a wonder if she paid came in what that
would do to the polls repay was pulling
actually in the hypothetical scenario
higher than the macro and but microns
pools are creeping up we're seeing the
pens falling away a little bit at the
moment if things stay as they are
there's still a lot of running less than
the race what if things did it they are
we've been looking at a macro m'lip in
second round I think most people were
there and hope expect and form a quarter
to pull ahead in the second round when
you look at the two candidates there
really is a gulf between them and macron
represents politics as usual in the
sense but he also represents and some
minor changer commitment to Europe a
commitment to reform in France and move
away from some of San Juans unpopular
policies but really not a huge distance
marine lepen is I'll be honest a
nightmare option she's Donald Trump with
an attention span and that's a nightmare
for all of us okay but we have seen at
what happened with in Austria with wiki
keep an eye on what's happening in the
Netherlands you mentioned Donald Trump
suggestion you know we are certainly
right of center here in the United
Kingdom it's not without a of
possibility that potentially it could be
marine lepen yeah absolutely it was
something which people were constantly
sharing couple months ago couldn't
happen absolutely no chance it's not
happening here and actually I think know
there is something quite different and
this is really a moment when people are
starting to get a little bit frightened
about the possibility of a lepen victory
and because at the moment emmanuel
macron androids are you know a huge
meteoric rise within the press he's been
treated very very favorably indeed he's
kept his nose clean he's nice to avoid
any type of scandal and really there's a
worry that people start to become
slightly tired of them I don't think
anyone could predict that fee on would
tank in this way and taking really his
party through the mud wisdom at the
moment I think the the best tactic that
people could hope for to avoid the Levin
victory yeah it's probably for free on
to hold on great to talk to dr. thanks
so much indeed